I'm really worried that banks are now
not genuinely competing against each
other they're all being forced to behave
in the same woke way and we are
potentially the victims
yeah it's just so concerning and I think
people really understand how serious
this is if you don't have access to a
bank account you simply cannot operate
in society it's completely impossible
when you go after somebody's money you
go after their livelihood I don't know
how Nigel farage is going to go ahead
and you know pay for groceries how he's
going to start accepting money for his
business I don't know how he's going to
be paying direct debits and electricity
bills when you know the winter comes
it's literally impossible we are moving
towards a casual Society we saw even
during covert that um was a catalyst It
sped up 10x
um you know people just aren't accepting
cash anymore and you know you you
mentioned wokism I think you're
completely correct there it really is
about having the wrong opinion only the
other week the bank of England made a
statement saying that all the genders
can get pregnant I'm not sure if you saw
that number one why is a financial
institution getting involved in social
issues I'm sure they should be focused
more on soaring inflation in the UK and
number two that's just absurd it's not
scientifically correct and so it can
only make me believe that the bank of
England believe in some kind of woke
social agenda and therefore have an
agenda and are clearly going after all
these individuals politicians political
commentators uh people in the church
that you mentioned going after them
because they hold the incorrect opinion
and I'm so glad that we're having this
conversation because you know sometimes
people don't care if it doesn't happen
to you you don't care Andrew Tate for
example he had his bank account shut
down and nobody cared now Nigel farage
is having his bank account and more and
more people are talking about it but as
soon as you have the incorrect opinion
they will come for your money because
money is the only way to uh disrupt
somebody's life Leia has the world
changed in terms of corporate Britain
Corporate America or have we just
noticed it because of social media
it's a really great question I actually
think the world has changed I think at
the turn of each decade things have
gotten more and more bizarre um you know
I'm only in my 20s I can't speak for you
know the last 14 decades or whatever it
is but I've noticed a change I've
noticed that um we're now not allowed to
say more and more things I've noticed
governments uh cracking down on certain
political ideologies I've noticed social
media cracking down on certain
ideologies
um banks are now getting involved I mean
you tell me did Banks shut people down
for having the incorrect opinion back in
I don't know two thousand well do they
have this rule in America can they can
Banks shut people down in America
because I wouldn't have thought they'd
in America you know the the dollar is
King
well I believe Kanye West has uh JP
Morgan didn't want to bank with Kanye
West because he said things about Jews
um but my opinion on this is that like I
said it's literally impossible to
operate in a society if you do not have
a bank account it's just impossible and
so I think that actually having a bank
account in the Western World should be a
right yeah you should you should be
there should be some kind of court case
if a bank wants to shut you down because
of course if you break the law then you
should have your rights taken away we
see that people go to jail and so on and
that's a good thing and so the same I
think is with a bank if Nigel farage has
supposedly done something criminal then
okay let him let him be banked for the
minute but take him to court that have a
judge let's do this I understand but
it's become like an authoritarian it
stinks doesn't it of coming from China
that sort of authority authoritarian
dictatorship type State doesn't it Well
the West absolutely love China I think
it was uh Justin Trudeau of Canada who
actually admired uh China's policies we
copy their covid lockdowns we copied
their vaccination rules and also we're
copying their Central Bank digital
currency so if you think it's bad now
what's happening with uh with these
shutdowns it's going to get worse with
the Central Bank digital currency which
they're working on what what worries me
about all this is the way that
Regulators who don't regulate have
started to regulate let me explain what
I mean by that look I've got a friend of
mine who went to prison for fraud right
and when he was released I met him and
had a drink with him the reason is
because you know he'd been released
right so fundamentally if he was still
considered to be dangerous to the public
he wouldn't have been released
presumably similarly uh he has now
served his punishment you know if his
punishment was not stiff enough then you
know speak to the court speak to the
probation service not me but what you
tend to find now is people go well Nigel
farage hasn't done anything wrong Nigel
farage isn't a convicted Criminal but I
have just decided that I don't like his
relationship with Russia which by the
way has been thoroughly disproved to
have been in any way improper but but I
happen to now decide that the police are
wrong that the courts are wrong that the
judicial service is wrong and I'm just
going to enforce my own Kangaroo Court I
think it's insanity
it is insanity and in my opinion I think
it's just going to get worse um the the
system and and the people in it are
getting more and more woke and more
divided it's why I'm a huge advocate for
Bitcoin because with Bitcoin you don't
have to trust that a bank or the public
opinion is going to turn its back on you
Bitcoin is completely decent what about
going nobody what about buying gold I
mean that's a one word Safeway isn't it
well go to gold is good but gold is like
holding cash so you can't really do
anything with it you know you can just
consider it and it looks pretty you can
always
yeah but for for money no nobody's
really gonna buy good services with gold
you can't accept you can't pay your your
your electric with gold you can't you
can't pay your employees across the
world with gold exchange like Bitcoin is
this one let me understand the arguments
in favor of cryptocurrency so I'm going
to tell you what I think and you just
tell me whether I'm right or wrong
effectively look first and foremost um
cryptocurrency uh what protects you uh
is the fact that there is a limited
number of Bitcoins that are going to
exist in the world right now obviously
if you look at what happens to the pound
recently every time the government wants
extra money it just prints more pounds
and creates a huge amount of inflation
now the advantage of having pounds in
your pockets it's backed by a central
bank to what extent you trust the
central bank is interesting but the
advantage with Bitcoin is that actually
people can't interfere in it they can't
suddenly print an extra million of them
or a billion of them when they want to
so whilst there's a volatility in the
value of Bitcoin you are protect from it
being devalued on a regular basis in a
way you're not protected if you have
pounds in your pocket is is that a first
summary
yeah that's absolutely Fair there's only
ever going to be 21 million Bitcoin you
cannot print more
um it's also backed by the mapping code
of the network it's also backed by the
fact that it's completely decentralized
so there's no one entity that just
doesn't like your opinion and one day
and could just hone your Bitcoin off
which will happen with a central bank
digital currency and that's the most
powerful thing about it so no matter
what your opinion is you are free to use
the money and I always want to make just
this point really clear that money is
the energy which fuels your life because
without money you just can't operate or
be a part of society at all so so I saw
an interview with an official at the
bank of England now when I say this
people figuratively throw rocks at me
but this official at the bank of England
said that the bank of England will never
launch a cryptocurrency but what they're
working on is where the crypto
technology will be a good means of
exchange and he gave the following
example right if you want to buy a house
what you do is you hire a solicitor the
other guy has a solicitor the money gets
sent to the solicitor and then there's
an exchange at the appropriate time if
you were to do that by blockchain
technology you could literally send the
money immediately and the contract would
go immediately as well he gave that
example now to me that sounds like a
sensible use of the technology but I
imagine you're going to tell me that the
fundamental problem with this is he's
lying and the research that's going on
the bank of England is actually to
launch their own cryptocurrency in
competition and under the control the
British States is is that is that is
that your position
so what he's referring to is something
called a smart contract and smart
contracts are actually brilliant and
they're done on the ethereum blockchain
and it basically doesn't it basically
removes the middleman and the blockchain
does it all for you so it's all very
great and stuff and you can actually
probably do that with this Central Bank
digital currency depending on what they
build however the the the debate here
and it's the same debate that we keep
coming back to is convenience over
democracy right it's the same thing you
know do you want to give up your freedom
so that you can do a quick transaction
well not not really I I don't really
want to give up my freedom and put all
the money in the centralized Bank of
England just so you know when I buy a
house it can be much faster
our Nigel farage Claire Fox and this
vicar I think he's called with the
Reverend father Gill uh forgive me if
I'm wrong on that but are these people
isolated examples or are we going to
start seeing a Crackdown on Free Speech
in this country motivated by a bank
regulatory system that nobody voted for
oh we are absolutely seeing a Crackdown
of it completely we're seeing it
globally and uh you know you asked me
has it always been like this and the
answer is no it's getting worse and
worse as the years go on into that it
was around 2010 that all this political
correctness or work could have started
to get worse 2020 was when it became
acceptable to start locking people down
and forcing them to take experimental
medicines and it's just going together
slicing isn't it a salami slice in our
rights right basically and they told us
that the world economic Forum that they
want us to own nothing and be happy by
2030. the writing is on the wall they
are literally telling us and so I'm so
happy that we're having these
conversations because we weren't having
these conversations back in 2019 and
2020 only recently in the last year and
a half two years are you know British
media really talking about this and so
it's getting worse so I'm not I'm not
I'm not one of the tinfoil hat Brigade
but the problem neither am I neither am
I I just want to make that clear but but
but what but what what worries me is
this right so I'm not into all this one
world governments and all this sort of
thing however the slight problem is
there is a trend here isn't there to be
obsessed with climate change there is a
trend here to be obsessed with
International organizations there's a
trend here to be obsessed with I don't
know a wolf walls for oil or whatever it
is but basically all the world leaders
get together it's fashionable to all
agree on these things and then they go
back to their own country and just
implement it even when people are not
very happy about the situation that
they've been faced with and and what's
really frustrating is if you look at a
lot of these policies every political
party completely agrees and therefore
you know okay you can vote for slightly
more tax in labor it's like less tax for
the conservatives but if you are
fundamentally against the idea of uh you
know International organizations telling
you what to do vote whichever way you
like you're not you're not God's choice
exactly and you know what unfortunately
I don't vote for that exact reason I
don't vote anymore I used to vote but I
don't how I do vote is with my money and
so I don't really leave much money in um
my British bank account I don't really
leave much in my American bank account I
leave most of my money in Bitcoin
because they because governments don't
have money they only have money which
they print and money which you leave in
their custody and so the less money that
I and hopefully everybody else uh
chooses to leave in their custody the
less power that they have because you
are completely correct it doesn't matter
who you vote for they're doing the exact
same thing I think Boris Johnson was
probably one of the most left-wing
politicians we had in the end he locked
us all down it was unbelievable
um you know uh Rishi sunak is is just as
worse it's truly unbelievable the the
whole thing with Ukraine I mean to me
it's just all rubbish are you
pessimistic about the future then you
know we just spoke to Stephen wolf who's
pessimistic is it all gonna
is that where it's going to go
it's a great question um I'm actually
I'm not pessimistic I think that we're
going to have two parallel societies uh
that have knots and have Yachts as I
like to say people who want to do
everything that the government says and
people who chooses not to do everything
the government says like myself who
chooses to go make money by themselves
so they're not relying on any individual
and doesn't leave money in a central
bank so for me nobody can nobody can
shut me down nobody can tell my I don't
have an employer so nobody can tell my
employer that I said something naughty
on the internet and so I should be shut
down and so I try as hard as I can to be
a sovereign individual so that I will be
in the have Yachts part of society as
opposed to the have-nots but the slight
problem later you are you know a highly
gifted individual you're somebody who
can write books who can trade currency
you know what what about the ordinary
man on the street who just wants to go
to his normal nine-to-five job and and
bring up his kids you know yeah you're
not pessimistic for yourself but it
sounds like you'd be relatively
pessimistic if you were him
yes I would be um and I think
governments are destroying the middle
class right now that's exactly what
they're doing people who have saved um
you know their life have now absolutely
nothing
um and so that is why I I do speak a lot
on the internet about this I do think
there are plenty of skills that people
can learn to make money online and
basically save themselves and save their
family and I talk about this all the
time and so the best that I can do to
help other people is through my content
through education teach people you know
about Bitcoin how to hold Bitcoin how to
custody it correctly so that when crazy
exchanges go bankrupt or run off with
your money like we saw with FTX at the
end of last year you will still be safe
so I I do feel a level of responsibility
to spread this message as much as
possible so that yes the average man on
the street is going to see himself so so
Leia look first of all what I always say
in these cases obviously if you take
Financial advice from a political
commentator like me then you're a fool
so you should absolutely not do that but
by high sell low but but what worries me
well I think the problem with Bitcoin is
this look I get the concept right and I
get the idea that you don't want to be
under the in the Hulk to a central bank
which is just going to print lots of
money and devalue your currency the
problem is there has been a huge level
of speculation in Bitcoin which has left
left it extremely volatile they've been
people who've gone in and literally made
it into a Ponzi scheme they've gone in
and said I'm buying Bitcoin today
because it'd be worth five times the
amount tomorrow now for me that that
volatility and that short-termism has
damaged the reputation of Bitcoin
yeah it's a great point but overall
let's let me put it into a bit of
perspective Bitcoin is 14 years old and
is currently trading at thirty thousand
dollars it survived the um it survived
the financial collapse of 2008 it
survived covid
um it's it's outliving the dollar and
the and all other Fiat currencies right
now it's at thirty thousand dollars it's
only really going up if you zoom out and
look at the chart I would never tell
anybody to trade Bitcoin and you know
you're going to be a millionaire
tomorrow the idea is that you want to
buy in a bear market and you want to be
at which we're in right now by the way
and you want to buy a a small amount
that you are or an amount that you're
comfortable holding for the next five to
ten years that's the trick I don't want
you trading buying and selling this is
this is this is expert stuff you don't
want to do any of that for the 21 1
million limit means it's not a Ponzi
scheme because a Ponzi scheme means it's
it's exponential so actually 21 million
Bitcoin maximum means it can't be I I
actually slightly disagree with that I
slightly disagree with that I'll tell
you why so if you look at the the first
major
um you know Market collapse in terms of
a commodity it was the tulip bulbs of
Amsterdam wasn't it so effectively what
happened was people were buying tulip
bulbs in order to get five times their
value you know two days later and then
in the end the whole thing collapsed now
my argument would be this first of all
there is still a use for tulip bulbs
right so the fact that you've traded it
Beyond where it should be traded and
turned it into a Ponzi scheme doesn't
mean that the that the product itself is
worthless and it doesn't mean that it
needs to be a Ponzi scheme the problem
you've got with Bitcoin is that people
have traded it in an irresponsible
fashion it doesn't mean that Bitcoin has
no use it and so I would argue that
you've effectively turned the market
into a Ponzi scheme when when actually
it
ought not to have been a Ponzi scheme do
you see what I mean well not not really
because like a Ponzi scheme means
there's no real economic value being
created and if everybody just withdraw
their money then you have nothing left
which isn't the case with Bitcoin there
is real economic value being created and
if everybody was to sell their Bitcoin
there would still be economic value
there would still be use case because
look how tyrannical the world is
becoming they're shutting down your bank
account okay and I understand that but
let me let me let me push let me push
back let me push back very quickly so
look first of all there is undoubtedly a
use for Bitcoin right there's no doubt
about that right you know it's a it's a
it's a system of exchange and it has its
advantages in the same way as the pound
has its advantages it has its
disadvantages they are different and you
are a strong advocate for it but I think
that when people are literally buying it
on the belief that it will go up four
times in the next three months that's
when it becomes dangerous and I think we
really ought to say to people and by the
way Leia you've done this today if you
want to buy it and go long term that's
fine but uh but actually if you're
buying it in order to make 50 times the
amount you've got now in three weeks
then actually you you really ought to
think much more carefully
but I think just because people treat it
irresponsibly I don't think that should
mean Bitcoin is an irresponsible asset I
agree that's just you know that's just
irresponsible practices and perhaps
that's something which you know the
establishment might want to teach in the
education system how to be responsible
with money and that's interesting that
they don't teach that either
um so you know I I would say hold
Bitcoin for the next five to ten years
you know I help my friends buy Bitcoin
and I say to them okay you're gonna put
some money in I want you to give me
money which you're not going to touch
for the next three years I don't want
money which you need tomorrow I want
money which you're happy to put away for
three five ten years and then over time
you will make your money you you will
the money will go up to one extent look
at the charts to what extent are you
interested in Bitcoin because you
genuinely believe it's good investment
and to what extent are you interested in
Bitcoin because you you you genuinely
believe that actually this is something
that we should all adopt as a system of
exchange for political reasons
um so I I'm very political at heart I'm
a freedom maximalist I'm a Libertarian
and so my interest in Bitcoin actually
comes from political reasons right um
and so that that actually shows me that
that drives my belief in the use case
and then I look at the technology and I
say wow it really is decentralized
there's really only going to be 21
million coins this fits my political
ideology this fits how money needs to be
and I'll also just add to this I
actually look at Bitcoin as more digital
gold than I do as a medium of exchange
of course right now it is a medium of
exchange and I do use it as a medium of
exchange I accept a lot of payment in
Bitcoin I pay employees in Bitcoin and
that's fine however I don't think
Bitcoin is going to be the currency of
the future I think it's going to be the
gold of the future
I mean you just to advise everyone you
could lose all your money in bitport
well where do you see it in five five
years time
um I think so as in a year from now in
April uh 2024 yeah that's a year from
now we're gonna have a crazy event for
the Bitcoin halving it happens every
four years and basically what happens is
the supply that the miners
um the the supply that the miners will
put out into the into the market is
halved and so now a massive scarcity
event happens and that usually Sparks a
bull run so for the next two years I
think Bitcoin is gonna is gonna run and
we're gonna see it past a hundred
thousand dollars I think early 2025 we
might even see it hit 200 000
um I think the Market's probably gonna
crash mid 2025 once it hits around 230
000 it'll probably crash back down to
the previous
um high of the previous cycle so I think
it'll probably crash around to seventy
thousand dollars
at 2 30. there you go well so whenever
you feel you've made good you could lose
all your money
okay Leia Halpern thank you so much
she's an author of undressing Bitcoin I
just want to make something absolutely
clear obviously Leia is a sophisticated
investor who understands the crypto
Market you must not under any
circumstances take Financial advice off
somebody you've seen on the TV or heard
on the radio more next